madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue en
direct sur le plateau de la voie libre
en Bourgogne trois semaines après les le
choc des attentats Charlie Hebdo à
Montrouge et dans le supermarché casher
de la Porte de Vincennes nous allons
parler d'un autre choc celui né du
constat que la nation n'était pas
forcément toujours réunis et rassemblés
il y a eu ici ou là des incidents lors
de la minute de silence de vive
réticence de la part de certains élèves
dans quelques établissements scolaires
et des enseignants un peu désarmés
parfois face à des enfants en rupture à
la avec les valeurs de la République
alors nous allons en discuter et puis
débattre des remèdes proposés par la
ministre de l'Éducation avec nos quatre
invités réunis autour de cette table
Denis Roland bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le recteur de l'académie de Dijon en
fait vous Dominique beau bonjour bonjour
la présidente de la FCPE de Côte-d'Or la
Fédération des conseils ou plutôt des
comités des parents d'élèves
des questions éducatives de l'éducation
au sein de la mairie et Gilles platreet
bonjour bonjour Le Maire de
Chalon-sur-Saône à la maison je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez poser vos
questions via Twitter notamment
#lve Bourgogne ou Ath F3 Bourgogne alors
ces dernières semaines les médias ont
énormément parlé des incidents
intervenus dans certains établissements
scolaires notamment au moment de la
minute de silence lors de la journée du
deuil national est-ce que c'est un
constat que vous avez tous fait est-ce
que il y a eu beaucoup d'incidents
Monsieur le Recteur en Bourgogne dans
votre académie il y a eu en Bourgogne
comme ailleurs des incidents des signes
de non-compréhensions de la minute de
silence et des nécessités de travailler
nos valeurs de républicaine et de la
sollicité c'est ce qui a nécessité du
dialogue avec avec certains élèves c'est
ça absolument et parfois plus que de
dialogue c'est à dire qu'il faut
comprendre
chercher à comprendre avec les élèves
avec les parents avec l'ensemble de la
cité scolaire et si nécessaire passer
au-delà s'il y a eu besoin d'une
réaction plus forte on a beaucoup cité
des écoles de quartier dit difficiles
est-ce que ça a été particulièrement le
cas dans ces quartiers à Dijon à Chalon
par exemple est-ce que vous avez noté
des incidents particuliers
pas plus dans ces quartiers que dans
d'autres moi je sais que j'étais sur la
minute de silence dans un dans une école
de centre-ville où il y avait eu un
petit souci le matin avec un enfant de
CE1 les parents ont été convoqué mais
enfin ce que je veux signaler aussi
c'est que la majorité des enfants se
sont et des jeunes ce sont ce sont bien
comportés et que c'était c'était une
grande majorité effectivement et que
c'est important et de toute façon
évidemment que ce soit sur le temps
scolaire ou sur le temps périscolaire on
mobilise nos énergies pour reprendre ça
soit avec les enfants soit avec les
parents mais bon les adultes aussi
étaient dans l'émotion donc c'est pas
toujours évident comment on gère ça
justement j'ai le plâtre avec cette
petite minorité c'est vrai qu'il faut
insister là-dessus mais qui existe tout
de même elle existe il faut pas la nier
il faut pas la grossir non plus je pense
que pour le catch Chalon-sur-Saône
c'était des cas très réduit et
d'ailleurs les les directeurs
d'établissements ont très bien réagi en
prenant immédiatement les sanctions qui
s'imposaient et je pense qu'il y a un
moment il faut rappeler la règle il y a
évidemment de la pédagogie on va en
parler j'imagine dans le cours de cette
émission mais dans des moments de
gravité comme ceci qui sont évidemment
liés à des événements qui sont d'une
pure tragédie où l'émotion doit aussi
être partagée c'est ça le principe la
mine de silence c'est comment est-ce
qu'on arrive à communier ensemble et se
retrouver après cette tragédie autour de
valeurs communes dans ces cas-là lorsque
il y a dérapages il y a sanction c'est
ce qui s'est passé d'ailleurs ça a pas
fait un pli et c'était exactement ce
qu'il fallait après il y a tout le
travail dont on va parler sur la
réaffirmation des valeurs de la
République et ça c'est un travail de
long terme qui ne se résume pas en
l'observant ou l'observation d'une
minute de silence impeccable c'est un
travail de fond qui va nécessiter
beaucoup d'efforts pour terminer ce
premier tour de table Domingo est-ce que
vous avez des remontées des parents
est-ce que ça a beaucoup discuté dans
les rangs des parents j'allais dire non
peu peu c'est vrai que ce sont ça
vraiment été on va dire certains élèves
ont manifesté de façon très minoritaire
il y a juste une chose Monsieur plâtrée
c'est quand vous parlez de sanction
je pense je pense que c'est jeune là
pour l'instant je parle donc des élèves
qui se sont exprimés de façon négative
ce jour-là sont certainement beaucoup
aussi sont dans l'adolescence et le
besoin de s'exprimer quel que soit le
problème d'être contre et je pense que
c'est là
entre autres et c'est là où nous adultes
que ce soit parent et là c'est vrai
qu'il faut qu'on apprenne vraiment à
dialoguer tous ensemble que ce soit
parent ou enseignants il faut qu'on
prenne en compte l'âge et puis ce besoin
ce besoin de s'affirmer et ce besoin
alors contre là ça pouvait être contre
et après la volonté on va dire profonde
et et là ça peut être les parents qui
qui sont contre cette laïcité qui est
vraiment trop importante un sujet très
important est-ce que ça veut dire quand
même ces incidents encore une fois qui
sont minoritaires mais qui existent et
qui font l'objet de cette émission
notamment est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il
y a des jeunes qui sont à passer tout
simplement au travers de la transmission
de des valeurs et notamment que doivent
véhiculer l'éducation nationale il
faudrait claire que nous devons mieux
enraciner les valeurs républicaines de
la citoyenneté et de la laïcité dans
l'école on a un travail
vraiment de à la fois de vigilance et de
meilleures transmission à faire c'est
fait et je pense que par exemple dans le
cadre des organismes de formation des
enseignants il faut rendre beaucoup plus
présent ces valeurs de la République et
de la laïcité on va détailler tout ça
votre collègue de quand je ne sais pas
si vous avez lu son interview à cette
dans Télérama cette semaine qui est
aussi historien et donc recteur à Caen
il dit il y a le feu à l'institution
vous êtes d'accord avec cette
constatation il y a pas le feu à
l'institution mais il y a l'obligation
de réagir comme le disait madame beau
vite mais en même temps profondément et
durablement on a le temps de la
scolarité entière de 6 à 16 ans au
minimum pour faire en sorte que tous nos
valeurs toutes nos valeurs soient
transmises que la liberté d'expression
soit bien comprise et que la laïcité qui
porte nos valeurs de vivre ensemble soit
bien enraciné dans la tête et dans
l'esprit de nos jeunes oui monsieur
plâtré je pense je vous parle contre
lire Monsieur le Recteur ce que je
partage ces propos je pense néanmoins
qu'il faut avoir un constat réaliste sur
la situation lorsque on détaille les
mesures que madame la ministre a proposé
à la suite des événements il mesure on
va évidemment en parler on mesure tout
de même
ce que l'école n'a pas su faire ce n'est
pas jugement de valeur par rapport aux
enseignants je parle de l'institution
dans son ensemble et de la volonté
républicaine qu'il apporte quand on
parle de réaffirmer la laïcité
l'autorité des maîtres le respect des
règles et toutes ces valeurs qui font de
le vivre ensemble ça veut dire qu'elles
n'ont pas été à l'honneur ces dernières
années et ces événements
pas assez en tout cas pas à mon sens
jusque là où elles auraient dû être
l'école de la République c'est le
fondement de la République c'est le
pilier républicain si l'école n'est pas
elle-même celle qui transmet ses valeurs
qui les apprend qu'il les fait partager
alors elle manque sa fonction elle loupe
sa mission et je crois que aujourd'hui
la réaffirmation sur le fond de cette
tragédie que nous avons vécu tous
ensemble au début du mois de janvier
c'est aussi le signe que nous avons
manqué un certain nombre d'étapes alors
encore une fois je ne juge pas les
personnes je prends conscience des faits
et les faits nous disent que nous devons
aujourd'hui faire ce que nous aurions
déjà dû faire depuis des décennies
je voulais simplement dire que l'école
n'est pas seule évidemment l'idée enfin
nous on prône beaucoup la coéducation
nous les collectivités nous avons aussi
les enfants sur un sur un temps qui peut
être pour certains parfois plus longs
dans le premier degré que que le temps
de l'école puisque les accueils de
loisirs commencent à 7h le matin et se
termine à 19h et de ce fait nous avons
tous un rôle à jouer collectivement et
je crois qu'on peut pas non plus laisser
reposer cette responsabilité sur la sur
la seule école sur les temps où les
enfants nous sont confiés par les
parents on a on a un rôle à jouer mais
aussi dans les associations avec les
associations de parents d'élèves et les
mouvements d'éducation populaire
évidemment alors j'y tâtré en parler à
la ministre le 22 janvier Najat
Vallaud-Belkacem a annoncé une série de
mesures dans le cadre de ce que le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale
appelée la grande mobilisation de
l'école pour les valeurs de la
République déjà est-ce qu'on peut être
clair qu'est-ce que c'est les valeurs de
la République parce que évidemment tout
le monde connaît la devise Liberté
Égalité Fraternité est-ce que ça va
au-delà ces valeurs de la République
l'école a transmettre de l'Irlande déjà
bien enraciné ce que c'est que la
liberté ce que c'est que et dont la
liberté d'expression l'égalité et la
fraternité nous avons tous du chemin à
faire l'école comme l'ensemble des
institutions autour et partenaires de
l'école pour enraciner ses valeurs déjà
c'est de faire comprendre ce qu'est la
laïcité ce socle depuis 1905 sur lequel
nous vivons qui fait qu'on construit du
respect qu'on construit du vivre
ensemble et bien c'est évident que nous
devons mieux enraciner cela et c'est
pour cela que dans l'ensemble des 11
mesures proposées par la ministre Najat
Vallou Belkacem il y a au cœur cette
idée de renforcer la transmission des
valeurs et je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait
un caractère aussi militant comme l'a eu
la Troisième République mil aujourd'hui
pour effectivement dans toutes les
disciplines c'est pas seulement le prof
de l'histoire-géographie toutes les
matières peuvent enseigner le respect
d'autrui la tolérance peuvent enseigner
ces valeurs de liberté d'égalité
fraternité ça veut dire aussi que vous
faites qu'on ait une pédagogie de plus
en plus interactive ou le dialogue la
discussion avec l'enseignant soit au
cœur de l'école
la mairie de Dijon a réinstalle je crois
de les frontons sur sur les façades
j'allais dire des écoles pas des
attentats
en fin d'année 2014 effectivement on
installe donc sur la façade de toutes
les écoles la devise républicaine avec
le drapeau européen et le drapeau
français de l'autre côté parce que c'est
que symbolique ou est-ce que vraiment
pour vous c'est une signification forte
inauguration avec le maire de Dijon le
recteur et tous les tous les partenaires
mais c'est surtout qu'on a demandé que
dans chaque école ce soit ce soit repris
justement avec avec les enfants parce
que
sur tout ce qui concerne la laïcité je
crois que il y a une grande confusion
dans la tête de certains enfants et voir
parents là ils citer était entendu comme
contre les religions il s'agit pas de ça
il s'agit bien sûr c'est au contraire le
le respect de croire mais la croyance la
religion doit rester dans l'espace dans
l'espace privé et on a des des lieux des
lieux publics notamment où on peut vivre
ensemble tous ensemble en dehors de ces
de ces considérations religieuses alors
c'est peut-être là la vraie question est
d'ailleurs il y a une question de Julie
qui nous dit comment former à la laïcité
concrètement c'est vrai qu'après tout
est-ce qu'on doit interdire tous les
signes religieux est-ce qu'on doit les
tolérer mais demander à respect de tous
c'est quoi la laïcité finalement à
l'école
madame beau peut-être pour les parents
d'élèves
la laïcité à l'école je crois que c'est
avant tout avant tout le respect le
respect de l'autre
le respect de ces enfants vous savez
quand on démarre à l'école maternelle
ils l'ont je pense qu'ils l'ont
naturellement ils l'ont la laïcité la
liberté il voit pas il voyait pas ce que
nous adultes nous mettons peu à peu
en place en place toutes ces frontières
toutes ces ils ne l'ont pas si on
pouvait continuer par le dialogue je dis
bien le dialogue alors après le dialogue
que ce soit les enseignants avec les
enfants ou les enseignants avec les
parents donc ça c'est vraiment la
communauté éducative si tout son pouvait
continuer à dialoguer après ils vont
apprendre il y a certaines choses qui
vont apprendre les enfants doivent se
construire ça va devenir des adolescents
j'en parlais tout à l'heure des
adolescents qui vont devoir se
confronter à l'adulte il faut qu'on le
permette il faut qu'on le permette aussi
bien dans la dans la structure familiale
que dans la structure au niveau de
l'école et à l'heure actuelle j'ai
tendance différents tant que parents
d'élèves j'aimerais que ce discours
continue c'est-à-dire que on est nous un
vrai dialogue avec le scolaire mais que
les enseignants aussi est un vrai
dialogue avec les enfants et pas
seulement je vais vous dire ce que c'est
que la laïcité que la liberté que non
non si seulement ça pouvait être un
dialogue je pense que par le dialogue
les enfants vont se construire parce que
maintenant c'est comme ça je suis désolé
la société c'est comme ça c'est le
dialogue et ce qu'il ne trouveront pas à
l'école pouvoir construire son esprit
ils vont aller le chercher où sur
Facebook sur Internet et là il y a pas
vraiment de dialogue là donc voilà un
peu notre idée sur la nécessité du
dialogue on est tous d'accord mais le
dialogue n'implique pas forcément une
négociation c'est à dire que le principe
ne se négocie pas il y a des principes
sur lequel il faut rester ferme la
laïcité doit d'abord être comprise parce
que vous avez raison de souligner la
difficulté de sa définition vous savez
sans doute que j'étais chargé par
François Baroin de co-présider un groupe
de travail
de France sur la laïcité on va commencer
par essayer de s'entendre sur une
définition de la laïcité et dans son
principe et dans son épure parce que
c'est vrai que ça peut donner voilà ça
peut donner à des recours à des
interprétations et pour c'est normal il
faut qu'on s'entende tous ensemble et ça
c'est une une vraie réflexion nationale
à avoir sur ce qu'on y met je pense que
le principe de base il faut y revenir
tel qu'il a été affirmé par la loi de
1905 c'est la séparation du fait
politique et du fait religieux c'est à
dire que nous avons un espace en France
qui est un espace public dans lequel les
religions ne peuvent pas imposer leurs
lois les religions ont toute latitude
pour se déployer la croyance est
respectée le mode respect est employé
tout à l'heure mais dans l'espace public
la religion n'entre pas elle reste à la
porte donc notre capacité aujourd'hui à
réaffirmer cette culture de laïcité elle
doit être ferme parce que si on commence
les accommodements c'est un mot hélas
qui est conforme à une réalité qu'on a
trop est devenu alors il n'y a pas de
fin vous savez quand on a quand on a
fait la loi de 1905 et même avant au
début du siècle quand les agents des
municipalités sont allés dans certaines
écoles décrocher les crucifix ça a été
un branle-bas de combat général faut pas
croire que la loi 1905 elle soit passée
comme une lettre à la poste les
catholiques ont fortement réagi
aujourd'hui les catholiques ont accepté
le principe de laïcité et bien
l'ensemble des religions doivent
aujourd'hui s'inscrire dans ce mouvement
c'est une démarche à mener mais c'est
une démarche qui consolide les
conditions nécessaires pour le vivre
ensemble parce que si chacun amène sa
petite loi dans l'espace public alors il
n'y a plus de possibilité de vivre
ensemble dernier Roland moi je crois que
la laïcité les valeurs de la République
ça s'enseigne dans les salles de classe
avec du dialogue mais ça s'enseigne
aussi dans les couloirs dans les
réfectoires dans les sorties scolaires
et c'est important parce que qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire
développer l'esprit personnel l'esprit
critique de chaque élève et ça c'est
dans le dialogue que ça peut se
construire ça veut dire garantir
l'égalité entre tous les élèves quel
qu'il soit quel que soit leur croyances
les croyances individuelles les
croyances familiales et puis ces
promouvoir la fraternité et ça si on ne
le fait pas à l'école et partout à
l'école et je peux vous assurer qu'on
fait mais qu'on doit mieux le faire
c'est évident qu'on doit mieux enraciner
et bien si on ne fait pas à l'école
Notre société serait en difficulté mais
j'imagine que voilà c'est c'est un peu
la théorie j'allais dire mais dans la
pratique est-ce que c'est facile de dire
bah voilà toutes les religions
s'arrêtent à la porte de l'école mais si
une jeune femme arrive voilée par
exemple qu'est-ce qu'on fait est-ce que
c'est facile pour les enseignants
justement d'intervenir il n'y a pas
d'enfants voilées à l'école il y a pas
de signe
ostentatoire de croyances quelle qu'elle
soit à l'école non il ne faut pas qu'il
y de façon à ce qu'il y ait du respect
dans la sphère privée on fait ce qu'on
veut et ça c'est le fondement de notre
République et de la laïcité on fait ce
qu'on veut on est libre dans la sphère
privée par contre dans la sphère
publique et particulièrement à l'école
il faut qu'il y ait respect et tolérance
et partout de la porte de l'école
jusqu'à la porte le soir de l'École
oui enfin moi je crois pas monsieur
plâtré qu'il s'agit de s'accommoder ou
de faire sa petite loi chacun de notre
côté simplement il faut aussi qu'on
puisse se mettre d'accord nous on a
dispensé des formations aux animateurs
et aux agents de restauration sur la
ville de Dijon sur la laïcité pour
effectivement que chacun comprenne bien
de quoi il s'agit donc il y a eu on l'a
fait avec
c'est la Ligue de l'enseignement qui
formait les les personnels et donc ça a
été extrêmement important de cette
formation il est ressorti une charte de
la donc qui est donc appliqué sur le
temps de pause méridienne réalisé par
les agents les agents eux-mêmes déjà il
fallait qu'ils arrivent à se comprendre
entre animateurs et agent de
restauration parce que les contraintes
ne sont pas les mêmes et voilà et donc
dans la mesure où il travaille dans une
même équipe il fallait qu'ils
comprennent il fallait qu'ils
comprennent le message politique il
fallait qu'ils arrivent à définir ce qui
était la laïcité pour eux et ce qu'elle
est en réalité et comment nous ville de
Dijon on fait aussi avec parfois
quelqu'un qui peut arriver voilé des
salariés temporaires voilà et donc
comment réagit et donc tout cela a
permis donc cette charte qui va être
donc distribuée à tous les employés et
tout nouvel embaucher et également dont
certains articles qui concernent les
familles vont être dans le règlement de
la pause méridienne alors ça laisse
dubitatif certains et je vais vous poser
une question Dominique beau vous
demandez en plus la part de Baptiste par
exemple je ne sais pas si on le voit à
l'antenne ou si on l'a vu à l'antenne
mais son tweet la laïcité devenue
religion d'État c'est un piège une
illusion c'est assez bien dit c'est vrai
est-ce que il faudrait pas d'abord
éduquer justement les parents les
adultes à la laïcité avant même
d'étudier les les parents je crois que
c'est Elisabeth Badinter qui disait ça
cette semaine
Dominique beau j'ai le plâtrer je vais
juste avant de répondre à votre question
je vais quand même intervenir
la laïcité est-ce que c'est pas aussi
si ce n'est au sein de l'école où on a
une normalement une réunion de
population au niveau des enfants il se
retrouve tous à l'école on va dire en
terrain neutre est-ce que c'est pas là
ou justement il doit se découvrir
découvrir leurs différences avec un
enseignant qui va être un arbitre qui va
être donc ça veut dire que l'enseignant
doit connaître je ne suis pas sûr qu'au
niveau des formations à l'heure actuelle
ils aient une connaissance
de toutes ces religions qui peuvent
arriver mais il y a un moment donné je
pense que si on veut être arbitre je
n'ai pas dit juges j'ai bien dit arbitre
il faut la connaissance de toutes ces
religions de toutes ces croyances de
façon à ce que les enfants on ne peut
pas quand ils arrivent en maternelle ou
en primaire on ne peut pas les brimer
alors qu'ils ont des questions et qu'ils
ont envie de se confronter entre eux sur
ce qu'il croit sur ce qui se passe à la
maison
et je pense que ça l'école c'est là où
l'école va jouer son vrai rôle et à la
limite pour moi elle allait à citer elle
est là
et ensuite peut-être une réaction de
l'Irlande
bon il y a une différence d'apprendre je
pense avec Madame bosse qui est pas
complètement surprenant parce que bon
peut-être de milieu philosophique qui
sont pas exactement les mêmes mais c'est
l'intérêt de confronter un petit peu nos
idées
un beau parle des différences moi je
parle de l'unité l'école effectivement
ne peut pas se couper de la société et
l'accueil les enfants tels qu'ils sont
mais elles les forment pour en faire des
citoyens et il y a pas 36 citoyens
différents dans une République nous
sommes tous individuellement différents
vies semblables de l'autre mais nous
avons une mission que nous partageons
tous c'est d'être des citoyens de cette
république et cette mission elle ne peut
s'appuyer sur un certain nombre de
principes et les principes qu'il s'agit
de respecter non je ne pense pas que
laïcité soit une religion parce qu'elle
n'est pas révélée c'est un travail que
l'humanité a fait sur elle-même elle a
et d'ailleurs c'est pas né en 1905
soyons bien clair en France on avait
pris le pli on ne fera pas un débat
d'historien Monsieur le Recteur ce que
vous et moi sommes traversés dans ces
matières mais on a petit à petit séparé
le temporel du spirituel dans ce pays et
on l'a affirmé officiellement 1905 donc
cette réaffirmation du principe elle est
tout simplement nécessaire parce que si
nous voulons préserver l'unité du peuple
français qui est en menacée aujourd'hui
par la montée du communautarisme en
particulier si nous voulons préserver
cette unité c'est effectivement à
l'école dans ce creuset de l'identité
républicaine que ça se joue
alors l'enseignant doit être un militant
des valeurs de la République il est
fonctionnaire de la République donc il a
un rôle fondamental de transmission de
ces valeurs et cette transmission c'est
pas dans un cours magistral
effectivement c'est dans un dialogue
avec les élèves dans toutes les
situations que ça passera le mieux mais
je voudrais dire aussi qu'il faut aussi
qu'on continue ce travail d'ouverture de
l'école aux parents parce que c'est
effectivement nos futurs citoyens ils
sont généralement formés à l'école donc
c'est là qu'on doit former les futurs
citoyens c'est là qu'on doit former les
futurs parents et puis s'il y en a qui
n'ont pas eu la chance de passer par se
creuser de formation et ça arrive ou
s'il y en a trop oublié ce qu'on leur a
enseigné à l'école et bien il faut aussi
qu'on ait des moments de formation de
ces citoyens de toutes ces populations
françaises il n'y a qu'une communauté en
France la Communauté française peut-être
qu'il faut le rappeler aussi et que quel
que soit les croyances et pas la laïcité
quelle que soit la pensée à l'école nous
devons former des citoyens de la
République
un mot d'un tweet là de Patrice alors
une réaction un peu vive à l'école
incapable d'apprendre à compter et à
écrire veut se charger d'éducation
civile morale et religieuse c'est un peu
exagéré mais c'est aussi sa mission
c'est pas hors de propos c'est
simplement de se dire qu'on doit aussi
bien apprendre les éléments fondamentaux
qui permettent de vivre en société que
de lire apprendre et compter que c'est
un tout indissociable et c'est ce qu'on
appelle le socle
oui tout à fait d'accord tout à fait
d'accord avec Monsieur Roland je suis
pas toujours tout à fait d'accord avec
Monsieur oh mais là je le suis il a
raison en fait c'est vrai que l'école
est un tout l'école doit avant tout
combattre l'ignorance pour moi c'est ça
le plus important
pour finir avec tout ce qui est religion
je ne vois pas comment les enfants à
l'heure actuelle on a une telle
diversité peuvent arriver à communiquer
entre entre s'ils ne se connaissent pas
s'ils ne connaissent pas justement et
accepter la différence et ça c'est avant
tout j'ai tendance à dire oui c'est
l'apprentissage de l'école alors bien
sûr bien sûr qu'il faut apprendre à
compter qu'il faut apprendre à écrire
qu'il faut apprendre à lire et qu'il
faut apprendre à connaître l'autre avec
ces différences et moi c'est là où la
République se construira
et c'est pas toujours évident on a vu
cette semaine un enfant de 8 ans
convoqué dans un commissariat à Nice
est-ce que c'était pas à l'école de
régler le problème ou est-ce que
vraiment voilà il fallait comme l'a dit
Cassen je crois c'était une bonne
réaction des enseignants d'aller
jusqu'au bout et de d'avoir cette
démarche pédagogique il faut laisser à
l'école aucun comportement qui ne
correspond pas aux valeurs de la
République impuni il faut comprendre
expliquer c'est ça la mission de l'école
donc c'est normal que l'enseignant
signal à son directeur signal à son chef
d'établissement les choses après la
réaction doit être ajustée entre les
mots de l'enfant et les valeurs de
l'adulte entre les mots de l'enfant et
la réaction adaptée à un adulte là il
faut ajuster et en même temps je pense
qu'il faut à chaque fois réagir c'est
l'obligation de dire on a une réaction
qui pose problème trouvons
une bonne attitude la bonne réaction
mais ne laissons jamais ces
comportements sans réaction je vais
peut-être vous tout à l'heure vous
parliez de fermeté il faut être faire
bien sûr il y a à la fois la réaction
face à des propos des actes qui sont
condamnables et qui pourraient
d'ailleurs s'il n'était pas un moment
donné sanctionné faire tache d'huile
c'est aussi la force de l'exemple disons
le bien et on citait tout à l'heure la
propagation sur les réseaux sociaux de
certains comportements aujourd'hui les
choses vont très très vite notamment
vis-à-vis des jeunes donc si
l'institution elle-même si nous-mêmes
collectivement nous ne sommes pas ferme
et bien nous laisserons la porte ouverte
à cette propagation finalement qui est
en sous-jacente qui est la violence mais
soyons bien clair ce travail il se fera
pas uniquement maintenant c'est le
travail d'une génération c'est à dire
que le débat que nous avons maintenant
en replaçant l'école sur ces bases
républicaines c'est un travail qui va se
qui doit se développer d'année en année
et pour finalement replacer les
principes au même de notre vivre
ensemble sinon il n'y a pas de vivre
ensemble possible c'est on peut tourner
autour des principes on peut on peut
dire on leur donne telle ou telle
définition s'ils ne sont pas réaffirmés
on arrive à des fractures sociales à des
luttes qui peuvent au pire arriver
jusqu'à des guerres civiles nous ne le
souhaitons pas nous voulons comme la
dimension recteur vivre en communauté
nationale dans ce pays quel que soit nos
origines dans le respect des uns et des
autres mais pour ça il faut réaffirmer
les valeurs 30 secondes madame Hélène
serre oui je voudrais pas être donante
mais on parle beaucoup de l'école et
effectivement ça fait partie de ces
missions fondamentales mais seulement
les enfants ils sont quelques heures à
l'école chaque jour et il y a tout le
reste de la vie il y a les associations
sportives les associations culturelles
les associations environnementales qui
jouent un rôle et puis les les temps des
sur lesquels il se trouve sur les temps
des collectivités
nous avons tous un rôle à jouer et pas
seulement pas seulement à l'école et je
pense que si on ne réfléchit pas
ensemble dans la coéducation comme on le
fait aujourd'hui
on y arrivera pas on va en reparler dans
un instant mais là il va être midi nous
allons nous quelques minutes pour voir
l'information à la mi-journée le flash
vous est présenté aujourd'hui par Arnaud
Lefèvre à tout de suite